for over a thousand generations the Jedi
Knights were the guardians of peace and
justice in the Old Republic where they
though okay so I kind of alluded that I
might do this video in my review of the
rise of Skywalker and also warning
spoilers for that I am gonna be talking
about some moments and that specifically
I am gonna be be bringing up something
that happens at the end but I do want to
talk in general about the Jedi and
whether or not they are perceived the
way they should be or maybe even the way
they were intended to be now
annoyingly film theory did a video that
looked like it was very similar to this
I saw the alert that it went up I
haven't watched it because I still
wanted to talk about this I didn't want
to see that and go oh well he basically
said what I was gonna say or in some of
the way Incorporated is - enough is to
point I still want to do what I want to
do and in addition to that let me be
clear because I'm not only say I'm not
going
the Jedi are really the villains know
they're on the right side but I think if
you actually closely examine their
depiction in Star Wars in the films at
least people can do and will always
argue of me oh but it extended the Dibby
Dibby but I don't take that into
consideration because aI don't read it
and B you need to swallow the fact that
the vast majority of people who watch
the films don't also take in all the
other stuff so I'm sorry if you feel
that doesn't make us real fans but you
need to swallow that pill anyways the
thing about the Jedi is they are very
much sort of mythologized and lauded but
at the same time if you look at how
they're depicted especially versus how
they're talked about there's some ink
agrees here and I'm not actually saying
that these are not meant to be
there but let's start looking at them
and I'm actually gonna look at these
films in the order of release as opposed
to the internal narrative chronology
which means we're starting with episode
for a new hope we basically just get an
idea of what the Jedi was we have the
quote that I did at the very start in
the opening from obi-wan Kenobi about
what he believes the Jedi were and
that's about it we don't get a ton else
we get a little bit about the force and
all this but exactly what the Jedi were
how they operated everything else not a
lot but one other thing we get a hint of
is that obi-wan and miss the fact that
Vader used to be his apprentice and he
turned to the dark side so obviously
whatever system the Jedi were using to
train and keep up with their own wasn't
flawless it was infiltrated it failed
somebody so we get the introduction of
this idealized idea of what the Jedi
were but also in the same film we get a
little bit of an undercut of it a reason
to question were they all that good and
that kind of gets elaborated on a little
bit further in Empire Strikes Back for a
couple reasons the first is not only do
we realize that you know exactly how far
things have fallen given that we
confirmed that Darth Vader was in fact
an can Skywalker and more to the point
obi-wan hid that from Luke
so did Yoda and there's it actually gave
me a mind that's not vastly a million
miles off from Dumbledore withholding
some very key information from Harry
that he probably should have known
before he went off and did or tried to
do a lot of the stuff that he did kind
of the same situation for Luke so again
we're seeing the Jedi making the call
that maybe they believe it's the best
thing but it Niki you got a question
like you could have prepared him better
you tried to just set him down and you
say don't go you could have told him why
you didn't this is a little on you and
then we get Return of the Jedi which
would appear to completely reaffirm the
idea that the Jedi are awesome and
amazing and
everything except we touch back again on
the reiteration of obi-wan and Yoda
either lying or withholding information
from Luke and you can give me all these
certain point of view lines you want I'm
sorry everyone you lied to the kid
flat-out to his face all repeatedly so
there isn't all that much in the
original trilogy good because the Jedi
are still largely thought of depicted
and talked about as this thing that is
past and they're not an active present
thing
Luke becomes the new standard bearer for
them of course and the two examples will
be got while I have reason to bring each
of them both Yoda and obi-wan into
question for some degree they're
undeniably good guys and they're doing
the best they can they maybe made some
bad calls along the way but we don't get
a ton on the Jedi but then then came the
prequel trilogy and the prequel trilogy
does a lot to demystify undercut and
bring into question the validity and
decency of the Jedi Order and what's
super interesting about this especially
if you want to compare it to you know
something like the last Jedi which a lot
of people got really upset about in
terms of what that did with Luke and by
extension with the Jedi as a whole and
that obviously came from a different
creator the prequels are from Lucas
himself so he himself decided to
basically show us how the Jedi actually
were and also not point out but leave it
to us to notice this isn't quite what it
was pitch dad so what was the main piece
of information we were given about the
Jedi the guardians of peace and justice
and how does episode one open they're
coming in to settle a trade dispute you
could argue maybe that's reflective of
the fact that there wasn't a lot of
turmoil going on for them to deal with
except no they're definitely kind of is
there's a lot going on but they're here
because of taxes that seems like minor
bureaucracy stuff
not grand sweeping guardians of
democracy and that gets made a little
bit worse once we get to Tatooine where
there's slavery and the Jedi
don't do anything they'd not even
surprise that their slavery going on
and yes they free Anakin but they free
him within the system that allows for
slavery they do nothing about that
system they leave it in place
they don't even bring up the possibility
of coming back to end of this cuz this
isn't this is not okay not even a
possibility not even an option
there's slaves people are owned used
abused not the Jedi's problem apparently
and then we get into Episode two and
there's some interesting stuff in
regards to the Jedi that goes on there
because they learn about the secret
Clone Army being made which they weren't
aware of and immediately like what is
going on here except they also fight
along excited they don't really they
kind of raise their eyebrows at it but
they don't really question it they don't
really do anything about what's going on
they do what they're told by the
Republic by the Senate by later
Palpatine they fall in line they're not
upholding a moral standard they're not
planting a flag and going we will do
what is right they follow orders now
maybe at some point in the distant past
there was a more idealized version of
the Jedi Order that actually was
independent and on its own upheld and
fought for these things but that's not
the Jedi as we see them not an episode
one and so at the very least I feels
like you can safely say that they as a
entity are badly mired in the system
that they are now a part of they are
trapped by it
and they don't seem to be doing much
effort to fix that or amend it in any
way and also let's point out it does
ultimately turn
out that Doku is a Sith and working for
the dark side but the Jedi go in and try
and stop him and try and undercut him
and try and get him to stop what he's
doing well before they know that and all
he's trying to do is take some planets
and have them not be part of the
Republic anymore
he's a separatist now depending on why
one is a separatist that in and himself
can still be a goal that needs to be
stopped depending on what reason it is
you were trying to break away from the
larger thing but right give it a ton as
far as that goes it's kind of presented
as if simply being a separatist simply
not toeing the line is enough that these
people this leader these planets need to
be brought in line under the heel of a
boot and the Jedi go with it and there's
also simply flat-out basic logistical
things that feel wrong or at best are
being applied very very selectively we
get told Anakin is too old for training
at nine and yet Wow Yoda made the same
argument about Luke in Empire Strikes
Back Luke is way more than nine minimum
three times that age I don't know how
old Mark Hamill was at that point when
he'd made that movie but yeah no he's
not he's not nine but the training still
benefits him does he become what someone
who was trained from a very young age to
become a Jedi maybe not but it works and
then and you know there's this all these
basic undercutting and another thing
that we get told once you go down the
dark path forever will it dominate your
destiny it's implied across the board
one toe into the darkness and you are
gone
Luke steps into the darkness he goes
right up to it he beats Vader in Return
of the Jedi by beating him down with
anger but having stepped over that line
having tasted that power he then steps
back and says no so again the dogmatic
proclamations of the Jedi are proven to
be demonstrably false or at least not
nearly the universal laws that they are
claiming that they are then we get to
episode 3 Revenge of the Sith and
multiple failings here largely having to
do with Anakin's fall first of all most
of the Jedi fail to recognize that one
of their own is struggling like this is
falling apart they don't do a lot to
identify or help or prevent it and even
obi-wan seems to keep defaulting to this
idea in his head oh he's the chosen one
it's fine he's the chosen one it's funny
since chosen one it's fine like by
basically doing nothing by upholding the
status quo by basically deferring their
responsibility and rarely ever making an
actual judgment call the Jedi cooked
their own goose because they could have
stopped Palpatine way earlier but they
didn't take action they could have
helped Anakin way earlier but they
didn't take action as an entity
regardless of what they were in the past
act by the end of Revenge of the Sith
the Jedi really don't have a function
anymore by the time they try and act it
is too late and they had the ability to
act way before that now we bring it up
to the modern trilogy and there isn't a
ton brought up about the Jedi in Episode
seven that doesn't basically fit with
what was done with the original trilogy
sort of general things said vagary the
lot of specifics last Jedi we get quite
a few more specifics and obviously I'm
naturally not a fan of the last Jedi but
I'm trying not to bring any of my
feelings of the individual movies into
this particular conversation so as far
as this goes you have Luke who tried to
re-establish the Jedi training oh and
look at that it resulted in effectively
the new Vader so whatever the training
regimen was that failed Anakin
and now failed Luke it doesn't work but
he brought it back because that's what
the Jedi were he was stuck in the same
traditions that were all that had
already failed the order from top to
bottom it had failed them it had led to
their downfall and he tried to bring it
back thinking I can do it better which
he couldn't it turns out and that very
rightly brings Luke to question himself
the Jedi
I think he's got more than a little
point when he says it's time for the
Jedi to end what good were they at this
point a counterbalance to the Sith okay
I mean I guess except they were hardly
the only ones fighting the Sith and when
not actively engaged in that very
specific relationship they didn't seem
to help
I see more often than not to either make
things worse or enable them staying the
way that they were in whatever broken
state that happened to be and then we
finally arrive at the moment and the
rise of Skywalker that made me go in a
minute because and again that's their
spoilers at the end when Ray's basically
hears the voices of the Jedi in her head
again sort of fitting into the what
purpose to do the Jedi have left well I
guess to counteract the sift so we have
Palpatine going all the Sith who ever
came before live in me where he
effectively gets the same thing for the
Jedi and taking an isolation it's a very
cool moment I like I love all the voices
we hear how many recognizable they're
ones including ahsoka from the Clone
Wars TV show that's really cool I love
it but what I think about it in the
greater context of the franchise as a
whole it's a very triumphant the Jedi
are awesome thing and not only do I
think they're kind of not I think the
franchise up to this point has agreed
that the Jedi
are kind of not awesome like I said
they're not the secret bag I sent out
the secret villains they're well-meaning
but incredibly ineffective at best so to
have Ray beat Palpatine in this big
triumphant celebration of the Jedi feels
a little odd and it's one of the things
that makes the rise of Skywalker feel a
little bit incongruous because what it
seems to be trying to say doesn't line
up with stuff said and virtually every
other entry in the primary films series
up to this point now I suppose one could
argue that what it's actually a
celebration of is what the Jedi were
supposed to be as opposed to what they
actually were which okay in theory I
suppose works except that the voices
that we hear are all the various Jedi
that we've watched over the course of
this film series fail in various ways
failing through lack of action failing
through backing the wrong horse in the
case of qui-gon obsessing with Anakin
and going that way failing because they
want a blind faith that things were
gonna work out and they didn't actually
pay attention to what was going on
around them failing and training failing
to be upfront and open with someone who
was going to be drastically damaged when
they found out the thing that you were
keeping from them and they were going to
find out it was an eventualities
all of them fail at what they try to do
to varying degrees and again I don't
actually think that's a fault I don't
think that's a mistake I don't think
that's a plot hole I think it's one of
the nuances of Star Wars that a lot of
people including very devoted fans have
a tendency to either miss ignore or
forget that the Jedi for all their cool
powers aren't actually very good either
at what they do and they're not very
good in the sense of being the upright
moral center of things because they just
fail to be proactive at all even
is completely reactive his restarts the
Jedi training because well there's no
more Jedi what's the reaction to that
train more oh it didn't work
kylo Ren happened what is his reaction
to that I go away
the Jedi are just not able demonstrably
throughout the film series to get on top
of things they're really bad at it we
just make that moment a little weird and
while I will say I don't think the
depiction of the Jedi are necessarily
fault or an inconsistency or anything
like that but that moment at the end
does feel like it's celebrating
something that the Jedi at least in the
timeframe that we have seen them never
actually were I'm not sure how I feel
about that coming to that sort of
conclusion as to how that fits into
everything else but it was interesting
for me to think about and I kind of
wanted to share my thoughts with you the
Jedi how good are these good guys
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
bunch of stuff to do as well like
subscribe share patreon all the things
more things there down below click them
or don't because at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]